Speaker 1: Let's speak to people people in the
audience. We take calls via discord. You can go to
David Pakman dot com slash discord. It's all free.
I have nothing to sell you in this particular
case. Other than a good time. Let's start today
with Ricky from Charlotte. Ricky, are you reveling
in the loss of Madison Cawthorn in your state?
Speaker 5: You know, I'm actually a little bit
upset. We never liked him. But seeing,
like, these videos come out, that
kind of normalized him a little bit. And I mean,
you know, seeing like him in, like, a more candid
sort of position and seeing that that's what
took him down. I really don't like that.
Speaker 1: Is that what you feel? Is
that the discussion in North Carolina,
that it's the personal stuff that took him down?
Speaker 5: Yes, without a doubt. Okay. You know,
people are like big, you know, decorum ninjas and
stuff like that. Yeah. Yeah. That definitely took
them down anyways. But David, you know, I wanted
to ask you this and and I want you to answer this
as honest and candidly as possible. Okay? I
recently kind of had an epiphany looking at, uh,
kind of looking at how bad things are right
now and how bleak the future looks. And,
and this is about everything, you know, it seems
to me like a lot of momentum is with the right
right now how strong and united they are. The
Republican Party is increasingly going into an
authoritarian fascist direction. Yes. On
top of that, the problems that we have with
this war, which I really don't like,
how it's it seems to be escalating.
And and the fact that we're still not
addressing big issues like climate change,
all of this, like, really does make me feel kind
of like what Chomsky was saying recently about
how we're getting like the Doomsday
Clock is ticking. So assuming you, like,
agree with a lot of those sentiments, is there
anything in spite of all this that gives you any
optimism or hope with all of this going on?
Speaker 1: I mean, it's it's sort of cliche
at this point, but it's that if you zoom
out a little, it does seem that things are
generally getting better. And I know that a lot of
people, it's very unpopular. Now, this is like the
Stephen Pink's Pink Star Pinsker thing. Is that
his name? And I don't agree. Stephen. Yes. Even
the the whole thing of how over time, you know,
death from wars has gone down and infant mortality
has gone down and all of that stuff. It doesn't
ignore that there's many problems that we could
have already fixed, like hunger, for example. But
I maintain, just like a general cautious optimism,
particularly with the idea that young people are
actually motivated to find solutions to a lot of
these problems. And so I maintain a long term
optimism, but I do think the next 8 to 10 years
could be pretty bad.
Speaker 5:
Yeah. I, you know, my my like the bar has
gotten so low for me. Like, I honestly, like,
I don't care about who wins the next couple of
elections. Mainly just want one the US to still
be a democracy in ten years. Right. We haven't the
whole world hasn't been destroyed in a nuclear war
and that there can still be something saved from
the planet, that it will still be inhabitable. Uh,
there's still something we can do to make it still
inhabitable for, like, next. That's true. I hope
so. Things that I want to see happen.
Speaker 1: And I'm right with you,
Ricky. I'm right with you there.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you for
the call. There's Ricky from Charlotte.